you scared the dog away today I'm
getting my dream pet for as long as I
can remember my dream pet has been a
pot-bellied pig and today I get to take
care of one I'm taking care of a pig
named Hamlet today I'm gonna meet her at
her house learn her routine with her
family and then we're gonna bring her
back to my house and see how we do alone
together I'm Melanie and I'm Michael and
we're Hamlet's humans I got her when she
was six weeks old when I bought her from
a breeder
she was a micro mini pig doing after I
found out there's no such thing she's a
pot-bellied pig what's the difference
between taking care of a dog and taking
care of a pay their behavior is not the
same a lot of people think that you just
train a pig how you would train a dog
but pigs are very different they
remember things sometimes they'll seek
revenge in like peein rooms so they're
really smart and they like to seek
revenge which I relate to you know she
gets into everything she's very curious
she needs constant attention we can't
leave anything out that smells good they
need to get to know you because they're
naturally prey they kind of like weary
of new people ending things this table
is all the stuff that she needs to live
her best life so I made a checklist
morning snacks is first on a checklist
pumpkin carrot I have an outfit for her
and the dressing started because of her
fair skin I relate to that I relate to
handle it more than I expected then we
have a harness and a leash a scratcher
very important pigs love belly rubs you
are gonna do Instagram do you want the
painted car yes okay let's pack her up
and take her home
so here's Hamlet
[Music]
you okay you want to go on an adventure
now I have my dream head for a day it's
happening it's really happening we're on
our own now and hopefully I make a best
friend today okay we're gonna I think
she's finding crumbs she might like me
more knowing that I have food around
[Music]
we're taking it for we're in my bedroom
now she's uh cleaning the floor and I
appreciate that she's a good roommate I
can't believe I haven't taken my bedroom
I'm gonna put her litter box in a corner
because I guess she likes foreigners
she's very messy let me wait you oh
she's mad Oh God oh you great using
animal life oh thank you oh she was good
she's like a little kid right look like
you need to wipe her face
who knows what song in and she just like
back I feel like she's having a good
time
I'm gonna take her out to lunch because
I'm a good friend and pet owner but I
need to get her harness on so that like
she's safe her mom told me like it's
really hard to put on her because it's
super tight
she doesn't really enjoy it so I'm gonna
just kind of do what she told me to do
which is like chase her down and like
get her head in there
[Music]
okay let me choose mine you did it well
did it matter lunch
trying to eat lunch and my pet pig is
making a great escape from her stroller
and I'm proud of her
that's crafty
you only know how that lunch was not
super comfortable mostly because people
just kept coming up which is fine but it
was also a little bit like intrusive in
a way that it was like they were
touching her and like I just got a
little nervous that she might get
nervous one of my friends is stopping by
just to like drop something off she
doesn't realize what's in my apartment
right now we weren't planning on like
hanging out but like just come inside no
oh my god what is that that's my Pig
pretty Hamlet you can go over to her
okay I forgive it all over the place
[Music]
you're gonna try to put on her outfit
because I promised her owners that I
would do an Instagram for her because
that's part of our daily routine and
it's gonna be interesting
[Music]
don't you like really need to like get
in there with this so I figured out how
to get it and I think I pulled it
through and now she's just like really
happy on my lap which makes me really
happy
I've never done a full Pig on my lap
before this is like
okay she has her pink car here we
brought it with us for this Instagram
opportunity that I was tasked with but
like we're so happy right now just like
this has to be really have to go yes
okay
I'm gonna put on one more like little
piece of clothing for her now she looks
beautiful but she always looks beautiful
[Music]
because I'm scared to go any further
[Music]
today was amazing I got my dream pet for
a full day we did a bunch of stuff and
now ending the day kind of just like in
my bed where I would sleep with my pet
pig just to have her here like burrowing
in my blanket in my room it's just like
it feels really special and it's
something that I didn't know if I would
ever get to do so I will say that taking
care of pigs is definitely not for
everyone you really do need space you
need time you need grass and they just
they deserve all the attention they get
but they do need a lot of attention I
might just stay here the rest of the day
the rest of my life so like you guys you
guys can go now bye
[Music]